what's up Wolfgang we have been treated
to a lot of great things lately
including some Avengers for leaked
photos and posters but along with those
we also got some leaked photos and
posters for Captain Marvel and not to
mention a young Nick Fury with two eyes
I must say these are awesome
these make me super excited to see
Captain Marvel because I think it's
going to be done very very well all
right let's jump into them will talk
about the photos first and then we'll
end on the posters cuz they're just
freakin awesome let's talk about this
standalone one first that's just her
with her arms out this is her pose and
photo from the Avengers 4 leaked photo
that we received a couple of weeks ago
it looks like she's flying which that is
one of her powers she can fly and it's a
great look at her suit right here and
the rest of these right here are sort of
just different variations of this
original photo and it looks like she's
in flight most of the time or it looks
like she's actually going to attack
somebody
and speaking of attacking somebody let's
talk about the sort of fire ish energy
that is surrounding her fist
Captain Marvel has the ability to shoot
light energy out of her hands but that's
not all she also has the ability to
absorb energy and when she absorbs
energy this light energy that she shoots
out has the strength of a nuclear
explosion so it's really cool that
they're accenting this and showing this
in these promo photos this next photo is
super awesome for one we see Carol
Danvers in her iconic flight suit jacket
we know that Carol Danvers is a pilot
and this is totally like 90s Top Gun Tom
Cruise wearing his leather jacket type
of thing right here and I dig it
so that's super cool but obviously the
big deal about this photo is we have a
young Nick Fury here with two eyes who
looks ticked off just like he always
does man why is this guy always mad I
always thought it was cuz you know he
lost his eye but he's got to in this
photo when he's still pretty mind but no
anyways
super cool to get a glimpse of this cuz
I'm really excited to see his character
you know pre the Avengers and I'm really
excited to see
a story that they give him and last but
not least are these pretty epic posters
that we have here you have the one on
the left that shows her kind of in space
and she's using the light energy beams
that I mentioned before look at her face
looks like she's mid attack and I'm just
I'm really excited to see her use all of
her powers on screen and then you have
this one that's in the middle here and
this is just the photo that we saw
before she's in a leather jacket she's
posing but they just made a poster out
of it looks awesome didn't you have the
one on the right that I need hanging up
in my office ASAP I love it
you have the one of her in action which
is actually the same photo from the one
on the left she just doesn't have too
light energy coming out of her hands and
then you have a still of her behind and
she's in space and I don't know I think
it comes together really well I like the
colors I just really really love all of
these posters so there you have it there
are the new photos that have been leaked
and the new posters that will hopefully
be coming out soon this is just another
glimpse into Captain Marvel that's
coming out next year tell me what you
all think of these especially what you
think of that young ticked-off Nick Fury
there and let me know which one of those
three posters is your favorite please
click that like button if you enjoyed
this video and these photos and of
course subscribe to my channel so you
can stay up to date on Captain Marvel
Avengers for all things Marvel DC and
superhero and of course thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]